este décimo aniversario de la guerra
civil se dice que el gobierno central de
bashar al-assad ha ganado la guerra pero
la realidad
es mucho más compleja el gobierno de
damasco no tiene el control de algunas
regiones del país especialmente en el
norte
en el país especialmente en rne
los diferentes grupos teniendo el
control de las ciudades
en la
islámico en 2014 que tuvo el control por
más de tres años dos grandes
consecuencias para la ciudad
especialmente por la destrucción y la
muerte que trajo pero también porque esa
batalla para liderar la dejó a la ciudad
prácticamente destruida sin mejoras
edificaciones siguiendo están todas
caídas sin muchas están muy de sus
debilitadas y ha sido un gran problema
para la administración que tiene el
control de la ciudad porque no tiene la
ayuda ni los presupuestos para
reconstruir la el enfoque ha estado en
volver a crear las condiciones para que
la gente vuelva a vivir y servicios
básicos tras la situación económica de
siga tiene grandes consecuencias para la
población actualmente